this is a production of Cornell
University
today I would like to talk to you about
exploitation of complex structure of
genotype by environment interaction in
cassava roots crop using IIT cassava
breeding program as the key study so
multi environment has allowed Britta to
scream for genotypic reaction to a range
of parameter condition if the nominal
people refer to as the denoted by
environment interaction this kind of
tree is usually converted at uniformly
track at the late stage of evolution
crowd to release all varieties a number
of ways such as crude method have been
proposed for exporting to notable
environment interactions so among them
are leaner by linear models such as
additive media freedoms multiplicative
interaction Moodle site accretion Moodle
sub to analytic model and multivariate
multivariate model so deep in principle
objectives of these studies to assess
complex root of G by heat interaction by
identifying optimum model with FIFA
grass cover structures so we also
interested in estimating genetic merit
of individual genotype toward
identification of speaker in no time so
to achieve these objectives so we tried
to put together a total number of 30
trials across nine locations until
increasing so those railway established
as a randomized complete block design
interior crickets so in total we have
the total number of world resistant
genotypes permitted across 30 trials so
in this study we intend to make use of
ours as an instrument for the analysis
so as you can see from this table these
two the number of trials for individual
environments and a political incision
you considered the data as if it a kind
of unbalanced structure
four defined as the number of traveling
from one location to the other
and for one who sees into the other so
to start with we try to come up with
this concrete measures to have idea of
the number of genotypes that is common
to any pair of environment so the key
message is that those environment that
have higher number of genotype can cover
so there is a likelihood of sharing
common information than those
environment that have less genotype in
coma
so after that we went ahead to a fight
of the distribution of the roots heat
which is our key trait of interest so
the key message from this board is that
deiayed seem to exhibit a Gaussian
distribution from one environment to the
other as you can see that the mean is
approximately equal to the median
another key message from this plot is
that there is a community of genetic
variance across the environment Mini
does this soil suggest the presence of
Ginetta by environment interaction so as
we all know that in a multi-level
maitreya the same trait measured in
different environment can be considered
to be different rates so we tried to
look at Pearson correlations among good
environment as you considered there are
some number of environments where the
condition is very hard I'm positive
so that means there is less of G by E or
mu G by induced kind of environments
there are some with positive correlation
that are very low so mineral there's
likely to be G by E industrial
government so we still have some
environment that are very cost
contrasting in the sense that the the
correlation is perfect and negative so
which suggests that there is likely to
be presence of G by he high G by G so
that is visual approach of assessing the
presence of G by or not so we we have
ahead to assess the process of debate
numerically so and here we are trying to
test a policies that there is no G by E
against all alternative possesses a
possesses that there is G by E mineral
the velocity by is greater than 0 so we
fit this nested body for the null
hypothesis without inclusion of Ginetta
by environment
so this same model is the parameterize
by inclusion of Ginetta by environment
interaction and this is the result we
got from the nested border and you
consider the variance component
estimated for each of this defect here
we have the similar trait for the food
model so I decide the queerest component
attributed to each of this factor so in
order to see whether the inclusion of G
by E is significant or not
so we have to cut out likelihood ripest
ratio test and by Becca different
between log likelihood of nester body
are full models who wish approximate
cast chi-square distribution with degree
of freedom equal to the difference in
the number of the parameter estimated so
I wish seem to be significant so which
tell us that the inclusion of G by E
makes sense and that cannot be ignored
as you can see here from this model you
consider the various attributed to G by
E is more than twice that of genetic
effect which means that G by is the
genetic bearers is specifically
environment and it's very large and G by
E is very important cannot be ignored in
this study so we went ahead to see if we
should assume that the arabela's is
similar across all those data
environment or ad add a heterogeneous so
we went ahead by fitting the full model
this time around we assumed that
arabela's diskette originals in each of
those environments and we fit the nested
model which assumed that the residual
Beres is uniform across all the 30
environments so this is restoring gated
by fitting the full model as you can see
the arrow balance range from two point
four two to ninety nine point six six
and for the nested border which
estimates which I assume what you know
from Arab urine samples or the
environment he was this result
so as usual we carry out the likelihood
ratio test which confirmed that as some
sort of error
Vera's eternity make sense and it has to
be taken to Constitution so that the
resort for the analysis will not mislead
us so in the next couple of slides I'll
talk about different kind of mirrors for
various structures we had we feed in the
course of trying to explore the complex
Russell of G ba he we started by fitting
compound symmetry model which is the
most restrictive of all the models so
this kind of model assume that the
genetic virus within the environment is
uniform and the qu the covariance or
correlation between any pair of
environment is also uniform so this
model may not be realistic will bad what
we saw in the in the previous slide that
the error variance etcetera he knows the
genetic virus within the parameters is
heterogeneous as well so this is
extracts from the model we fitted so if
touched by 30 matrices but there's no
way we can visualize everything at once
as you can see I know you crucified
Algona those are the degenerative URIs
readily apparent which are uniform of
the diagonal that is the correlation
between any pair of environment so we
went ahead to fit compare symmetry at
Regina's model which is just extension
of the previous model so here the
correlation between any pair of an
environment is uniform and what makes it
different from the previous model is
that the genetic variance across the
environment is heterogeneous and this is
the result obtained from that model as
you can see another piece about the
Iguana these are the genetic variance
estimated in each of their government
which is unique based of the double is
the coronation
pema's coordination between environment
which is uniform so this is another form
of modeling we fitted and this is the
most liberal of adi model it is liberal
in the sense that it's fitful g'bye
without structures so in this kind of
model we assume that each environment
has unique genetic variance and
correlation between any pair of
environment is also unique so fitted
this kind of model you have to estimate
what enlighten umber of parameters take
the sample which started number of
trials in our story so that means we are
going to estimate around 465 parameters
so we try to fit it and is the error
message we got so this means it is not
only computational inefficient to fit
this kind of model that also
computational prohibitive so we fitted
factor analytic model as well factor
analytic model in smoky boards just miss
model and a lot of army which is
additive may be feted multiplicative
international model so this is a model
that is a kind of lower order across
measure two on structural models so
which factor analytic model you can
identify related common factor that
capture understand the G by E pattern so
as you can see this is our structures on
the photo analytical models looks like
and this components Phi is specific
errors in nature of the environment and
this square of loadings
plus this specific bearers who give you
the generating Vere's in each of the
environments I'm using this to
illustrate when you feed button and
unfit model of Ottawa and of the
diagonal is the genetic covariance
between any pair of environment and is
just a matter of dividing this genetic
virus by the square root of the
of these areas and these barrels if you
interested in knowing the genetic
correlation between any pair of
environments so after fitting all this
sort of models so we we try to use a
goodness of fit statistic to be able to
identify the best mother duck
asking the contest papa and G by E as
you can see from attacking information
criterion so that was that in fact Oh
analytic model of a tattoo is the most
parsimonious model explaining the
complex strategy by which 114 parameters
and by looking at di see it identified
compound symmetry as the best model a
lot of people prefer to use attack
information criteria simply because the
di C imposes ended penalty on the
complex model by identifying a simpler
model so we go for akaike information
criterion so after identify factor
analytic model offer that to what animal
would other tree's are you have to
multiplied but applicative component so
and this is the result we obtain from
facto analytic model for that - so the
first two column here that is what he
called deleted common factors which
explain the complex pattern of G by E
and this column here that is what you
call spacing informal specific variants
in other what this de Vere's in nature
of this environment that is not captured
by this latent common factors so what
would he about this factor analytic
model is that when you have information
about amber meta
variables like precipitation the
temperatures so you can decide to look
at correlation of course environmental
variables with this lated common factor
to be able to identify which of the
environment upon variable is very
relevant in explaining G by E
interaction so from this photo analytic
model from this littered photos so when
you take the square of these and this
Plus this one that will give you the
genetic variance in
which of these environments so the key
message is that our photo analytic model
of either to capture a total of 60
points 90% of the variations where the
first component and separ component
accounted for forty two point one and
18.8% or the finish respectively so the
lesson learned and take-home message
from this study is that the cop
asymmetry murder fits is simply D by a
structures they are very easy to fit and
comfort easily they are recommended if
it'll fit in confident confidence trust
cannot be found even though they do not
provide better understanding of G by a
structures construction model is
computationally demanding as the number
of environments or try keep increasing
so in analysis of mud environment rafts
it is very rare for people to use this
model because you may you may you may
end up having a solution that is not
contract factor analytic model is very
parsimonious and an effective approach
for dissected G by E in this stage of
where you have a large number of trials
so the next step is to see how we can
identify a subset of environment with
and without crossover in these studies
and we also plan to incorporate still
make metadata into the model to see how
we can capture the relationship among
those genotypes so at this your son I
like to test the Gates Foundation UK
head for the financial support my
appreciation also put my committee
member for the pieces of advice word of
encouragement and pan to everyone in the
lab and our collaborators as well I
thank everyone for give me attention
thank you
okay thank you very much but it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu